- Wow. 100,000 subscribers
on my Firm Learning Channel.
This is really crazy.
Thank you so much for every one of you
who was part of the journey.
When I started out in January 2020,
I would never have thought,
I would never even have dreamed,
that I would be able to
reach this milestone,
especially, not in this amount of time.
So welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning,
and the topic of today is Staffing.
So the process how consultants
get on their new projects
can choose, or maybe not really
choose, their new projects.
How this all works,
and I will share tips
in three areas with you.
First of all, I will explain to you,
hopefully also some non-obvious things,
why the staffing process
is really important
and really decisive
for your future career.
Second, I will explain to you
how staffing processes work
in most large consulting firms.
And third, I will give
you a couple of tips
what you can do to steer
the whole staffing process
in the right direction.
So stay tuned.
Now without further
ado, let's dive into it.
So let's start by discussing
why the staffing process
is really important
and you should take it
really, really seriously.
Because indeed when most firms
impose some kind of structure
and some kind of rules on you,
in most of the cases,
you do have flexibility
to steer the process in the direction
that you wanna have it to go.
So first of all, maybe some
rather obvious reasons.
If you do not take influence
on the staffing project,
you cannot really make sure
that you really do the projects
that you want to do.
Maybe you're interested
in specific industries,
in specific functions, specific topics
that you wanna learn more about.
Well, it is your
responsibility to make sure
that you steer the staffing
process in the direction
that indeed you have the opportunity
to do exactly this project.
Next is the people.
While most people you
work with in consulting
will be great, will be inspirational,
will be people you can
learn lots of things from,
as in all firms, there are differences.
Probably some people will
be a bit more inspirational,
a bit more great to work with than others.
Probably you will also,
on a personal level,
connect with some people
better than with others.
So make sure that you really find
the people that you wanna work with.
And that in the staffing process,
you also get staffed on these projects
with these people that really
resonate well with you.
Next, the reason why
staffing is important to you
is because you need to strategically think
about your exposure.
If you always work together
with the same partner,
with the same one or two project leads
for an extended period of time,
and then your next
evaluation session is up
and maybe these people give
really great input on you.
But think about it,
what will be more strong
to make your case to be a high performer,
to be a rockstar,
to potentially get that
fast track promotion?
Will it be strong if only
one person, one partner
cheers for you and tries
to make the case for you?
Or will it be stronger
if several partners,
several senior employees of the company
will make the case for you?
So generally, you wanna make sure,
while it is great and helpful often
to really make bonds
with individual partners,
you wanna make sure that
you have a broad exposure,
that there's a certain set of people
who can all say positive things about you,
who will cheer for you.
This is the best way for
you to really make that case
of the strongest performance,
to make that case for the fast promotion.
So if you are looking for your staff,
before your next staffing decision,
have your exposure matrix in mind as well,
to also look at this
from the strategic angle.
So how does the staffing process works?
And of course, it's important
to mention in the beginning
that there are differences firm by firm.
Some processes would rather tend towards
giving you as their consultant
lots of freedom in the choice.
And other firms will rather push you
towards certain projects
that they feel like
their most valuable ones.
But in the end, with
pretty much all firms,
you do have significant freedom
to re-steer the whole process
in the right direction.
And how it works is that
you usually can imagine
the staffing process to be
like a marketplace, okay?
So on the one side of the market,
they're all the consultants.
All the consultants that are now available
or just coming out of a
project that has now ended
and they're now looking for new projects.
On the other side of this marketplace,
they are the new projects
that are starting
and more precisely, the partners
that just sold the new
project that now need a team
to conduct this project.
And these are the two sides.
Pretty much like a demand
side and a supply side
that need to come together to
then form the project team.
So let's try to put
ourselves into the shoes
of these two market participants,
if you wanna frame it this way.
So first, the consultants.
What do they wanna do?
Well, they of course
wanna have the project
that interests the most,
that is most closely
aligned with their goals,
where they can work
together with the people
that they wanna work together with,
and so on and so forth.
So they will have very strong preferences
on what they wanna do.
On the other side, the partners.
What are they looking for?
Well, they wanna make sure
that the project that they're about to do
that they promised the client to deliver,
that they have the best team possible
to make this project a success.
And this usually means that
they're looking for consultants
who already worked on
similar topics in the past.
So this is like one very big requirement
that's usually there.
But then the other second important one
is also, they're looking for consultants
that are just high performers.
Consultants that have a
reputation of being rockstars,
of being those that just
really always deliver
or always doing a great job.
So what does this mean to you?
Well, if you're a consultant
and you wanna do a specific project,
if you have already done
related things in the past,
this will really help you then
to do more things in that direction.
So usually just getting
the foot in the door
with a new type of project,
a new industry, a new function,
is the most important one.
After you've done that a couple of times
and made a name for yourself,
it will be much and much
easier going forward
to do more project in that direction.
But then of course, your past performance
and your reputation in the firm
will be extremely important
in your ability to secure new projects
to really work on the
things that you wanna work.
Another factor that plays into
this process is seasonality.
So there are some times of the
year, typically the summer,
when not that many new
projects are starting.
So this time, there are lots of associates
'on the beach' as it is called,
who are looking for new projects
but not that many projects that start.
So these times of the year
can be quite difficult
to really find the best projects
to exactly the projects that you wanna do.
But then on other times of the year,
usually also the start of a new year,
there are lots of new projects going on.
Here there's really lots of projects,
lots of demand for
associates, for consultants
to start on a new project.
And in these times of the year
will always be much easier for you
to really get your choices
to projects that are aligned
with your preferences.
So it is important to understand
this marketplace dynamic
of the staffing process.
And make sure that you also network.
Build your network within the firm
because these are really the things
that then will help you in the long term
to really do the things that you wanna do
and follow your passions.
So as promised, let me end
with a piece of advice.
Because there's one thing
that is very commonly done
by pretty much all more senior consultants
but then the junior ones often
don't really understand yet.
And this is the importance
of doing due diligence
on your future project team.
So, let's imagine that you're in contact
with a new project that is starting
and it sounds quite
interesting, it sounds great,
it sounds like something
you would like to do.
And that's really
important, the next step,
that you make a due diligence on the team.
And probably here the
most important person
to do the due diligence on
is the project lead.
Because the project lead
will likely be the person
that determines most
how your daily experience
will be on the project.
So what does this mean?
What exactly can you do?
Well, my experience is
that this is something
that is so common practice
that it's just absolutely okay
just to directly ask that project lead
if you talk to that person.
"Can you name me a couple of references?"
"Can you say me a couple of names
of people that you
worked with in the past?"
Usually then, these people
will be more than happy
to provide you a short list.
And then you should reach
out to these people,
either with a short email
or ideally on the phone
calling them up saying,
"Hey, I saw that you worked
with this person in the past,
can you tell me a couple
of things about the person?
How was it like to work with that person?"
Then of course if the project
is already ongoing for quite some time,
also ask for the names of the people
who work currently as
consultants on the project
or maybe worked on the project
a couple of weeks, a couple of months ago.
This is also great way
of getting a more independent opinion
or more independent impression
of what it's really like to
work there at the moment.
Because often the situation,
the experience is not only
determined by your own team
but also how the client team is set up.
So how are the clients like
that you would interact
with on a daily basis.
Are these people fun to work with?
Are they great to interact with?
As you can imagine,
there are also huge differences
on the client's side
that can also significantly
shape your experience.
My additional point here would be
to always be very deliberate
on how you ask the questions
if you conduct such due diligence.
Because it is the most cases,
other consultants will be quite hesitant
to not blatantly say
that a certain person was
terrible to work with,
that it was super difficult,
super bad, the whole experience.
So often, unless you really
know already these people,
the feedback will be much more nuanced.
So one question that I
always like to ask is,
"Okay, on a scale from 1 to 10,
how much did you enjoy working
with that project lead?"
And here, my experience was,
if people really loved that person,
they will tell you,
"Well, on a scale from
1 to 10, it's a hundred.
It's a 20. It's 50. It's like much more.
It's 10 plus to work with that person."
But then if you get a response of like,
"Ah okay, it was a 5 or a 6
to work with that person."
That probably would be something
where you would wanna dig in to that,
be a bit more careful.
Then of course, you can also ask like,
"If you would need to name one thing
that was really not great,
that was really something
where this project lead
needs to improve on,
what would that be?"
But if you're really
like pressing the person
to name one or two or three things,
what are these people then telling you?
So these are really the type of questions
that you wanna go for.
Don't go with too soft,
too open questions.
Because these then will likely
give you too soft answers
that are not really insightful
for you for your decision.
So now I'd love to hear your experience.
Does this resonate with our sharing today?
Is this also matching your experience
if you are a consultant as well?
But also let me and the others
here on the Firm Learning community know,
do you have any other
tips from your experience?
What are the little tricks that you use
to steer the staffing process
in the right direction?
Let me know in the comments.
I trust these would be valuable
to many other people out there.
So as always, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also hit the subscribe button
to stay up to date on more my content.
And also turn on the notification bell.
If you want to see even more from me,
I also have an Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
You also can find me on LinkedIn,
link to that in the video description.
And I also want hand out a big thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Thank you for supporting my
work here with this channel.
If you wanna become a member as well,
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to sign up.
This was Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday
on this channel.
So see you again. Talk to
you again next Saturday.
Good weekend to all of you. Bye bye.